la expresión cuadrática x cuadrada más 5
x c es un cuadrado perfecto y se puede
factorizar como x + d elevado al
cuadrado tanto pse como d son números
racionales positivos y el objetivo de
este vídeo es descubrir basándonos en la
información que tenemos cuál es el valor
de ce y cuál es el valor de verdad
entonces se es una constante que hasta
ahora es desconocida y lo mismo ocurre
para d así que te invito a que hagas una
pausa y trates de descubrir por tu
propia cuenta quién tiene que ser se y
quién tiene que ser d
muy bien entonces lo que vamos a hacer
nosotros es considerar este polinomio x
cuadrada 5 x c de hecho voy a escribirlo
x cuadrada + 5 x + c y tenemos que
compararlo con esta verdad que es x + d
al cuadrado ahora bien el enunciado nos
dice que esta expresión cuadrática es un
cuadrado perfecto y de hecho se puede
factorizar como x + d al cuadrado así
que esto en realidad será igual a x + d
elevado al cuadrado así que podemos
tratar de desarrollar este binomio al
cuadrado como lo hemos visto en vídeos
anteriores entonces esto será igual a x
cuadrada más 2 veces de x x
de cuadrada verdad entonces es
esencialmente lo que hemos hecho en este
paso es desarrollar este binomio al
cuadrado para obtener este polinomio
cierto así que si esto te causa quizás
muchas dudas
quiere decir que quizás necesites
revisar los videos sobre factorización y
trinomios cuadrados perfectos muy bien
por todo esto lo puedes encontrar aquí
mismo en la que anna academy muy bien
entonces esencialmente a la hora de
elevar al cuadrado este binomio
tendremos x cuadrada más dos veces el
primero por el segundo verdad que sería
2 de x x o 2x por d da lo mismo y de
elevado al cuadrado eso es lo que hemos
obtenido hasta ahora ahora bien lo que
podríamos hacer es lo siguiente si
tenemos este polinomio del lado
izquierdo y este polinomio del lado
derecho los coeficientes tienen que ser
iguales así que por ejemplo 5 tiene que
ser igual a 2 de verdad entonces
tendremos que
de es igual a 5 y por otro lado
tendremos que esta constante c tiene que
ser de cuadrada muy bien entonces
escribimos e iguala de cuadrada ahora
bien si desarrollamos de este lado
tendremos que d es igual a cinco medios
verdad simplemente dividimos de ambos
lados entre dos y ahora esto lo podemos
sustituir en la expresión que tenemos
para hacer verdad esto será igual a
cinco medios elevado al cuadrado y
entonces podemos concluir que se es
igual a 25 sobre 4 muy bien entonces
aquí ya tenemos la expresión para hacer
que es igual a 25 cuartos de es igual a
5 medios y hemos terminado